617 830 for 750 is the number if you
have a question that's the number to
call if you have a concern that's the
number to call if you merely want to
check in about anything 617 830 4750 is
the number who is on with me next hey
David a snitch for Vancouver Washington
Mitch great to hear from you what's on
your mind um so I am very passionate
communication and I'm studying
communication school and I love to do
things in regard to journalism and media
I was wondering what got you started in
compassion that your turn right now in
terms of politics or in terms of media
media well it sort of was an accident I
mean I when I was in in college and I
started in communication I was already
interested in politics and the idea of
doing a show sort of fell into my lap
because a local community radio station
opened called WX oj also known as Valley
free radio is our first affiliate and I
thought hey i'll just try out doing a
show and talking about politics and i
sort of built the passion by doing it
wasn't something I was necessarily uh
decided on doing from the beginning so I
tell people that the show kind of
started because of boredom and grew from
there well now i know it said you know I
it would be amazing if I could come to
you and say you know from the time I was
three I would have a fake microphone in
front of me and I would pretend I was
hosting a show and it was always what I
wanted to do it might be a cool story
but it would be a total lie well thank
you you're a great inspiration of mine
thank you really appreciate it really
appreciate the call and uh Mitch please
call in again vancouver washington
always great to hear from you